absolutely they're right wow i'm blown
away by both of these it's just
so flat the tree is so flat hey guys
it's max and this is my brother
vadim and my sister angelica and today
we are doing another unbiased
blind camera comparison with the brand
new iphone 12 pro max
the galaxy note 20 ultra and the pixel
5. now you might be wondering how is
this a blind
unbiased comparison well um yesterday i
went out and i took a bunch of photos
and some videos
we have 30 different samples here and
neither of these two have seen them
so today i lined all of them up we're
going to be looking and choosing they
are
which one is their favorite without
knowing which one
and then we're going to see the results
and we want you guys to
grab a piece of paper or take out your
phone
and play along with us so you can see
which one of these phones take the best
images
for you not what brand you like now we
already did this video with the regular
12 pro but we're gonna do it again
because the pro max has an updated wide
camera and the telephoto
and the note 20 ultra also got a
software update
and along with that i'm excited because
i actually went through and looked at
all of these images
and i rank them one to five so five
being
i can't believe it's coming from a
smartphone one being
i probably would delete this photo and
so i actually don't know the results of
what i
ranked all 30 of these shots we're going
to look over and at the end
i'm going to find out what the overall
scores are so
this is the first shot right here this
is
early morning the sun came up and let me
know what you like better
all right so this one's pretty tough but
i think the center is over saturated it
looks really nice but it's kind of too
much
the one on the right is too flat so i'm
going with the left
yeah me too for sure that the one on the
left looks pretty detailed
the one in the center definitely looks
kind of fake almost like it's art and
then the one on the right is just so
so flat twelve pro matches first one
this is a shot using the telephoto so
zooming in and also low light that's
actually a very very tough shot there's
a lot of lighting in there
center instantly this is your your
preference what which one would you want
in your phone
i definitely think the center one's the
best make sure you guys are voting and
following
along and then if you guys need more
time just pause it as soon as the image
shows up before
we tell you guys our opinions and that
is the 12 pro max wait
is this a zoom shot this is a zoom shot
this is like 10 times
zoom and i gotta say i wasn't expecting
it because
this actually has a telescopic optical
zoom crazy camera
and the iphone has a 2.5 times zoom now
slightly better than before
but it did a good job look that's not
blown out right here either the damage
range more detail a little bit more
noise but
surprising standard camera here
yeah i think i'm going with the right
the one in the center i liked but i
started noticing all the noise in that
sweater in the top everywhere so
the right is the cleanest
12 pro max and this is a portrait shot
and it was super windy so this is a very
tough situation hair's flying all over
this is a really tough situation but i
think i'm gonna go with the center
i'm noticing more kind of detail
everywhere
the one on the right there's like some
weird flaring going on and like some
weird stuff going on with the skin i
don't know what that is
i don't know something about the center
one just feels kind of off
okay no love for the pixel
i really liked the like the blur
portrait of it even though it kind of
blurred out some of her hair
this is a tough dynamic range shot they
all actually did pretty good job because
the sun was coming out it's super dark
here uh i think i like the
one on the left the most i'm going with
the center
i like that one i feel like the one on
the left might be brought up too much
i feel like the one on the right kind of
crushes the darks
and i like that in the center i'm seeing
like detail in the bushes and stuff so
pixels look at that another for the note
and here is our first
selfie it's backlit here all right with
this one honestly i think i'm going with
the right i'm seeing the most detail
in the hair the beard everything the
most detailed even though the skin
looks a little bit warm i'd still prefer
that like over the center it's kind of
like
weird and pasty i'm definitely going
with the left
actually left pixel five so
the cooler white balance is correct here
but i love the note 20 ultra
shot i was like amazed by how good it
looks like that selfie is awesome the
iphone they haven't fixed
um selfies blowing out the background
all right and we have
a food shot on the grill and even though
a couple of these look like portrait
shots they're not
i'm going with the right man that
chicken looks good
it's so crispy like all that little
detail you see yeah pixels
first one for the pixel yeah i want to
say surprisingly when you're this close
i didn't expect the pixel to have some
natural blur
because it has by far the smallest
sensor but you still still get some
of course pro max bigger sensor and then
note 20 as the biggest
but this looks horrible i don't know
what the heck happened and we have a
portrait shot
this one is kind of off most of these i
lined up perfectly this one i tried to
do a wide portrait and one of these
phones
wouldn't i mean i'm going with the right
i think the center it's too much blur
it looks just fake because it's just it
looks like he's been photoshopped into
it
yeah the right looks actually really
natural like a regular
dslr would do and 12 pro max so it was
interesting that it let me get this
wide the pixel actually crops in when
you do a porsche but it let me get back
far enough
but then some of the blur is just weird
and messed up the note 20 actually
didn't let me get that far back
and this is the first video and i know
some of you guys asked for more videos
so we do have 5 out of 30 our video
clips here
and let's go ahead and play it back and
you guys can watch it back a couple
times if you need
center easy already yep the right
there's just so much
sharpness and just weird stuff going on
same with the left
i'm going with the one in the center
because the outside two kind of made me
feel sick
that is the 12 pro max so um looking at
this screen i'm seeing a lot less
differences than on the 6k
display on the 6k display it was really
obvious
in every single way and here we have a
zoom shot
easy this is about 10 times zoom center
look at that easy no 20 ultra
and here we have a portrait mode with
the telephoto i like the one on the left
all right i'm also going with the left
it was between the left and the right
and i just don't like how the right
looks so flat and i think it's too warm
all right and no 20
ultra the pixel 5 has a crazy amount of
blur
this is me shooting against the sun for
those backlit situations where
flaring can come up instantly the right
yep so easy like
barely any flaring so what's the second
best
well they both suck left of course
they left the second hole like this is
unusable and the pixel 5
with its small bump without the extra
rings
and smaller sensor and the iphone with
these
beautiful gold rings and stacked up get
a lot of reflections
bless you this one here is a macro shot
with the sun hitting the leaves
i mean i'm going with the right first of
all it's not blown out
the center is blown out and the one on
the left is just kind of
dark um if i were completely honest i
kind of like how the center one is blown
out
i think it looks really nice that's kind
of magical i'm gonna go with that one
okay and this one also is not a portrait
shot it's just close up
and here we have one more video once
again you guys can
go back and re-watch it before we find
out which one is which
center hey dude stop
they all have a lot of flaring
all right so i'm going with the center
because the one on the right first of
all
so much sharpness it's horrible
the one on the left i think it has like
artifacting and it just doesn't look as
good
even here when it froze like your face
is all flat the center has the best
dynamic range
and everything is super sharp it's not
over sharpened
i agree 12 pro the pixel just loves
sharpening
it's crazy and this is a shot of
uh charcoal being lit honestly i like
the one on the left
i feel like it's overall the best
balance the one in the middle looks
really cool because it's dark and you
all you see is the flame but i feel like
it just crushes it
too far i definitely 100 like the one in
the center
the most with the left one why do i want
to see all that detail for
i don't want to see that i don't want to
see that i want to see what's important
you guys at least agree that this one
looks the worst yeah the one on the
right is the worst
all right and pixel 5 is for vadim oh i
got to pick some nice
and uh 12 pro max it just exposed for
the fire
it looks so cool and now we're getting
into night mode so that was already at
sunset it's getting dark at four o'clock
now
i love the one on the right like look at
all the detail you get everywhere
it's not too warm i feel like the center
is too warm and if you look at the
the parkade whatever that is it's not
blown out
but you also get the blue color and it's
nice and sharp too that
kills it pixel five man that's good so
we're gonna see
if the pixel is gonna make a comeback
actually you have a good amount of pixel
votes so yeah so for vadim maybe
and i do also want to mention that we
are going to be comparing the 12 pro
max to the 12 pro that doesn't have that
extra zoom
and that sensor that sensor shift so if
you guys want to see that make sure you
guys subscribe
and then with that you guys can help us
reach 500 000 subscribers before the end
of the year
and this is another video example
so let's go ahead and take a look and
you guys can always rewind
and check it out another time if you
need it
i mean this is night and day like this
is mind-blowing
the biggest thing is the colors the one
on the left
it looks really great but the the other
two look green
and there's so much stuff that's blown
out they're all like way too
like warm and just weird and right here
i mean this is i mean this is incredible
the left just killed it so
so well so iphone wow
once again and now we have our first
nighttime portrait shot all of these are
super weird
okay so the first photo the the portrait
like on all of them
got kind of messed up especially the
center one there's so much stuff here
that did not get blurred out
on this one the cutout in the back is
like all messed up there's a little bit
here too
but it's not as bad and it sucks i
really like the center photo
but this is just so messed up yeah i
would agree i really really wanted to
choose the center until i noticed how
bad it messed up here and i noticed all
the reflections from the lights just
which totally ruin it i mean you could
crop
in but it's just i don't know kind of
ruined it for me and this also has
reflections too
yeah but you don't notice it as much
this one's just horrible like it's all
blurry it's
not sharp at all like i don't like that
at all i'm going with the left
there you go oh man so notes right there
that pixel one looks really good but
that is really bad
i don't know what the iphone did and
night mode except for
this time we have the ultra wide camera
man the center is killer
center man look at that it is so sharp
and that light it looks so good it's so
sharp it's not smudged out like these
two it's like blurry
you guys already chose that i'll point
this out this looks so flat and evenly
lit like everything's so bright
where this you have the dynamic range of
the light but then it gets darker
shadowing it looks like a dslr shot
and it's a 12 pro max that is killer and
here we have
a portrait shot at night in in a dark
alley
with very dark lighting so left easy
look at that
easy pixel five
that one's way better and the note i
actually took the note shot a couple
times
did you because i saw that it was just
uh smeared it's like out of focus and it
uh it's it's too too long um exposure
yeah that's the exposure is just too
long and it kept blurring it out i
try to be fair to it but and we have
another portrait shot here
i really like the one on the left
because of the detail looks really good
but
seeing some weird kind of like fading
at the top right and also like her boots
are kind of crushed
as far as the detail i really love the
center even though it has a reflections
which are kind of weird
the center just good it looks good and
it kind of matches the lighting
it's warm lit i really hate the
reflection that's going on
it's just so weird though it's one in
the center
doesn't look the best there's like a
million lights here which is not your
typical situation i think the photo
itself
is like the middle she looks the best
and most natural but that's just so
weird so are you voting i'm gonna go
with the left okay 12 for max for me
that's killer and we have one more ultra
wide
shot here i think i definitely like the
one on the left
see i think the center is kind of like
too bright it's kind of overexposed with
all the reflections and stuff
the one on the right i was liking until
i saw the tree
and it's just so soft so i think for the
most
balanced i think the left
and this is a zoom shot
at night i think this is four times zoom
and this shot there's a ton of
differences a ton that i wasn't
expecting
i'm going with oh man that's hard they
all suck
oh no that's hard can i skip no you
can't skip i mean there's some
i don't want to get i can't i'm not
saying anything yet but i don't want any
of these in my phone
all right so the one on the left i kind
of like it because you're seeing the
detail and the brick
however the clock is blown out for some
reason
and the sky doesn't really look dark it
looks kind of gray i really like the one
on the right
the sky is really dark so you get some
contrast
in between them i think i'm going with
the right overall i like the contrast of
the sky
the center one looks pretty awful but if
i had to have one of these in my phone
i think i'd rather have the right one
because i feel like you could do
something
to kind of make it look better to fix it
but the left one is just so blown out
i don't think you'd be able to bring the
detail back no you can't
pixel five wow the one the one
phone that doesn't have a telephoto zoom
at night time when you're doing zooming
in four times
looks the best and the one phone that
has a four times zoom
these two are digitally cropped in the
one phone has a four-time zoom
looks the worst and here's another shot
here so this is a two-time
zoom shot left easy left i mean you look
bad
you actually get a black sky and
everything i mean everything else is
horrible look at that it looks like
night time pixel
five once again and that's right two
times zoom
digitally these aren't digitally cropped
this is
actually maybe the note is you might
need to use the other sensor
i don't know so here we have a portrait
shot
i think i like the one in the center the
most it's definitely not the right
i don't like how that looks at all it's
definitely not the left between the left
and the center i kind of like the left
but i'm seeing so much noise
everywhere that's the only downside i'm
still going with the center yeah just
like you
12 pro max the one on the left is the
worst one dude
no that one i'd rather have that in my
phone than that okay guys you agreed on
the one that you
chose all right and this is the
spokane falls so this is a nighttime
shot which actually when you have a long
exposure blurs out the water which looks
really cool
all right so the center is garbage yep
this is so much artifacting
between the left and the right i think
i'm seeing quite a bit more detail
on the left 12 pro max
and i think this might be the last one
but i don't remember
center i love the contrast of the center
like you've got
very black sky right there and it's also
really sharp as well i think yeah center
for sure
i think in this photo the center one
does look like it has the most detail
and it looks the best but then the
second would be the the one on the right
twelve pro max so this is using the
standard lens
on all of them a night mode shot
absolutely they're right
wow i'm blown away by both of these it's
just
so flat the tree is so flat but look you
have different colors
there's so much dimension on the right
like you got the leaves you got the
green
wow and you have shadowing in the shadow
shadow spots and then you have bright
spots as well i chose the scene
that is incredible because of these
lights it was so dynamic at night
that's the iphone and the one on the
left
the other two just look kind of like
smudge they're soft
almost look like they're out of focus
yeah the one on the left and it was
extremely dark they're not none of these
are out of focus it was just
so dark super dark okay yeah it's 12 12
pro max and look the front
the front camera hasn't changed at all
yeah but you guys see how dark that
contrast is so it's the processing has
changed
and it's more sharp yeah and then the
notes all flat here
and this is a video let's go ahead and
hit play
and it was like crazy dark outside as
you can see
i mean center right
from the beginning the center on this
freeze frame i'm seeing the detail in
the tree it's the only one that shows
detail and the lights are nice and crisp
black sky i agree
and then this surprised me look at that
you have all the dynamic range here
instead of
all the blown out smudgy mess impressive
and that's the 12 pro max and once again
this is without dolby vision enabled
because we
couldn't do the comparison so and i
believe this is now the last shot
hopefully it's the last shot all right
so i just stared at these for a little
bit
and it's between the left and the right
the one in the center is just kind of
like
flat and the sky is all kind of artifact
great kind of great easy now
easy the one on the left the one on the
left looks a little bit flat with all
these buildings it's all kind of like
flat
whereas you're getting a lot of contrast
in between all the details on the right
so
the right is so much better like that
chase sign is not as blown out you can
see it inside here
you can see a lot more detail this
there's so much blown out in there
kills it
there you go good night mode and that
is it so you guys make sure you guys
pause right now
count up which ones you voted and make
sure you comment down below
and then tell us if you were surprised
by anything you guys count up
i got 16 for the 12 promax
i have seven for the note 20 ultra
and i have eight for the pixel five this
time
i also have 16 for the iphone really but
i have
six for the note 20 and nine for the
pixel so i got a little bit more than
this one
hey and then for me i'm excited to know
what these averaged out to i know some
of you guys
asked for this because like in this
situation both
the 12 per max pixel 5 both looked good
and only one gets the point which makes
a bigger difference
um so i rank them from one to five and
what is my result alright so i averaged
them out earlier
and that was before she saw any of the
photos or anything at all
see the order so the pixel got
3.4 average out of five okay
the note got a 3.2 average out of five
and the iphone 12 pro max got a 3.86
wow so that shows you guys how close
these phones are i will also say that a
lot of the situations here were very
tough um very tough lighting
and stuff like that if you're in perfect
lighting all these phones are gonna do a
great job
uh so it looks like the iphone got you
said 3.8 compared to 3.3 and 3.2.86
um i noticed a difference in some of the
cases where the pixel lost
it's because it didn't have a good zoom
camera it has to digitally zoom in on
the main sensor to do portrait shots
of course it does great in low light and
it didn't do very well in video
by far did the worst in video uh the
note 20 ultra
it actually got a lot of fives i did a
lot of
awesome shots but it also had by far the
most
ones and i don't think uh pixel got one
one iphone iphone didn't have any ones
and then the note 20
edge has just situations where the sky
looks grey or there's all this
artifacting
because of all the extra processing it
has to do because of its sensors and
resolution
whereas the 12 per max is all around
good and then of course
the video shots that we had it it kills
it
in video so but it's nice to see that
overall score so make sure you guys let
us know
what scores you got and if anything
really surprised you
down in the comments section below and
if you want to see the comparison
against the 12
pro and maybe the regular 12 to see how
much better is the max is it worth
getting the larger size
make sure you guys subscribe down below
and there's a couple other great videos
right over there this one max and
my team and then thank you guys for
watching we'll see you in the next video